en este vídeo los invito a que pausa en
el vídeo y ustedes solos indiquen cuáles
son las fracciones que representa la
parte coloreada en rojo en cada uno de
estos círculos los invito a que lo
marquen en una recta numérica ok
empecemos uno por uno veamos este
círculo amarillo que está dividido en 1
2 3 4 5 partes y una de esas 5 partes
iguales está dibujada en color rojo así
es que podemos decir que una quinta
parte
de este círculo amarillo está dibujado
en color rojo vamos con este círculo de
en medio ahora este está dividido en uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve diez partes iguales de esas diez
partes iguales sólo tenemos dos
dibujadas en rojo así es que tendremos
dos décimos de este círculo dibujado en
rojo hagamos lo mismo con este círculo
azul lo tenemos dividido en uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez
partes iguales y también tenemos dos de
esas diez partes iguales coloreada o
dibujada en color rojo vamos entonces a
dibujar nuestra recta numérica vamos a
hacer una recta numérica que vaya del 0
al 1
les parece bien esa será la parte en
donde nos enfocaremos y empecemos con
este círculo vamos a dividirlo en cinco
partes iguales para que podamos marcar
nuestra unidad
pongamos 1 2
5 aquí se colocará el número 1 que será
nuestra primera unidad en nuestro primer
entero y está dividido en 5 partes
iguales si tenemos este círculo amarillo
con un quinto dibujado en color rojo
vamos a marcar una de esas 5 partes en
nuestra recta numérica para colocar
donde se encuentra esta fracción así es
que será una de las cinco partes
y aquí se encontrará un quinto un quinto
para poder marcar el resto de los
círculos vamos a hacer una cosa voy a
copiar y pegar esta misma red porque ya
la tenemos hecha
y una pobre aquí
perfecto tenemos este círculo dividido
en 10 partes iguales habíamos dicho así
es que marcaremos en nuestra recta
numérica la división de 10 partes
iguales no sólo 5 tendremos 12
y marcaremos entonces los dos decimos
vamos a cambiar el color una vez más a
rojo así es que iremos 12 veces y
estamos exactamente en el mismo punto
vamos a colocar aquí
decimos el tercer círculo es la misma
situación
tenemos dos décimos queda en el mismo
punto y será que estas dos fracciones
están representando exactamente el mismo
número si de hecho tiene sentido vamos a
escribir un quinto
es igual a dos décimos son fracciones
equivalentes y tiene sentido esto se dan
cuenta se encuentran en la misma
posición dentro de la recta numérica
como es que esto tiene sentido incluso
si lo vemos este círculo amarillo no
tenemos dividido en 5 sin embargo si
dividiéramos cada una de estas partes a
la mitad
tendríamos entonces
tendríamos entonces 10 piezas 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 de la misma manera que los
otros dos círculos e incluso si se dan
cuenta tenemos la misma proporción
dibujada en rojo lo ven es por eso que
un quinto como teníamos originalmente
dividido nuestro círculo amarillo es
igual a dos décimos y porque tiene
sentido también con este porque
finalmente tenemos diez piezas de las
cuales dos están coloreadas con rojo sin
embargo lo que aquí hicimos fue separar
las primero las teníamos juntas y ahora
las tenemos por separado sin embargo
siguen siendo exactamente el mismo
número y es importante que aquí noten
que no hemos dibujado más nada
simplemente lo que se hizo fue dividir
esta parte en dos y separar la tenemos
exactamente las mismas proporciones de
esta manera podemos concluir que
efectivamente un quinto es
igual a dos décimos marcados desde
nuestra recta numérica lo podemos ver
como fracción e incluso visualmente
tenemos forma de comprobarlo
nos vemos en otro vídeo